welcome you're attending the first of
the MIT nano seminars first of the ones
that will be coming over and over again
for decades to come I would hope the
first set of seminars we refer to as
perspectives in nanotechnology as we
wanted to make sure that as we
inaugurate the beginnings of the seminar
series
we could ask luminaries from across the
world those who have made significant
strides in understanding and defining
the field of nanotechnology to come over
and share with us their understanding
their expertise and indeed to launch us
onto the journey that MIT Nano is
undertaking which is beginning of the
new era the new age of nanotechnology
that is just upon us for our very first
seminar we have asked a very special
professor to join us from Stanford
University professor Roger how he's the
William Ayer professor of engineering at
Stanford University and indeed an expert
in his own right in MEMS technology
micro electro mechanical systems
technologies and variety of other
related fields
now what Professor Howe has done in his
time indeed is remarkable not just
because he has visited and stayed and
taught at a series of universities
starting at CMU where after finishing
his ph.d degree at Berkeley he decided
to join CMU only realizing back in the
1980s that CMU did not have as good of
ism of a micro fab as MIT just opened so
in 1985 he joined MIT and indeed stayed
with us in a very early days of what
this became known as micro assistive
technology labs or MTL seeing it grow
from the very beginnings to what it
ended up being an entity that right now
supports over 700 users and indeed who
has grown to the point where we needed
MIT Nano in order to facilitate the next
era or what needs to be developed from
there he went back to Berkeley spent
time designing yet another Nanofab
Berkeley is a newest Nanofab that opened
in 2010 but he left before
hope and only to go to Stanford and yet
again participate in the another program
that indeed supported the
nanofabrication at Stanford and beyond
so his perspectives today will be to
give us a chance to understand the
beginnings of this nano age and to chart
the path forward Roger please take over
thank you and thank you to Professor for
Naz Marie for the idea of getting this
seminar series underway and it's a
privilege to be back at MIT so I would
like to focus on something that would
would distinguish nanotechnology is a
huge area a lot of it would be
nanoscience nanoscale sciences I'm gonna
focus more on the engineering of the
technology side and start off with a
brief history some of the people in the
room were around in 1959 some were in
diapers in 1959 most weren't but
actually nanotechnology goes way back
and you probably or some of you may be
familiar where the story of Richard
Fineman I'm going to give you my take on
that and then to be at MIT in the
mid-1980s there was a lot of
nanotechnology going on and I
intersected with some of that and then
at Caltech in January 2000 you have an
event that's not a scientific discovery
but a political change in funding you
have a national nanotechnology
initiative that is now whether it's
started in 2001 it's celebrating its
15th anniversary and I think in in fact
it goes back to around 2000 so it's
getting old enough to vote and that is
rare I'd like to look at lessons learned
and what Stanford's been up to and
general comments on shared fabs and how
there might be opportunities in the 20s
which are upon us to really accelerate
this translation out of these labs
rather than they will translate
eventually we want to make that quicker
and then look at a case study on some
strange fabrication that was involved my
own group as an example of how labs are
being forced to be much more flexible
and draw some conclusions so way back
when I wasn't living far away in Los
Angeles Richard Fineman gave a talk
called there's plenty of room at the
bottom at an American Physical Society
meeting and some people have said well
this is really the kickoff of
nanotechnology encouraged scientists
especially physicists to look at the
micro scale rather than outer space
because there were many many things that
would be interesting scientifically and
to encourage people he had $1,000 prize
for a very tiny electric electric motor
and someone wanted who was a Caltech
staffer who was a good machinist and
built this by hand as a one-off $1,000
which was a lot of money then I was
probably too easy
his other prize was won in the 80s by
Stanford students it involved putting
lots of information and you needed an
STM for that so actually I was a grad
student I never I certainly actually
didn't go to Caltech but I attended one
of fineman's lectures at the invitation
of my high school friend who was a
Caltech I was at a school you may have
heard of Harvey Mudd not far away drove
over Feynman's lecture was incredibly
entertaining and quantum electrodynamics
I was a physics undergrad it was sailing
a few light-years over my head but I
hadn't heard of this until it was dug up
later so it didn't really percolate into
the applications in the 80s
Jeff Lane Steve Centuri and I was
students Steve Bart trestle Oberon
louver and Marin mega maragon II got
going with poly silicon surface micro
machines and this is a micro MIT micro
motor and this helped kick off a whole
industry in your pockets you have
polysilicon accelerometers and
gyroscopes and in
act the word spread not that there was
efficient ways of spreading the word
then but I got an invitation to the MIT
nanotechnology study group spring of
1986 to talk about this exciting
research as a young professor you have
you know enthusiastic students and
progress and so I actually the talk went
over like a lead balloon they were
totally underwhelmed this group was
organized by Eric Drexler who was a
staff member I think in Space Sciences
lab and later a PhD student in the Media
Lab but he had launched the group to
discuss a vision of a make Meccano
synthetic molecular nanotechnology and
he had a new book out called engines of
creation and you may have seen some of
these this is Ralph Merkle and Eric
Drexler in this molecular differential
gear that's animated so it was a totally
total mismatch in fact we were just
doing the same old stuff that people had
done since possibly the Stone Age
chiseling away removing things and they
were you know so who cares in any case
there's been that disconnect over the
years between people who are using
lithography and people are using
synthetic techniques I I think there's
room for both in the late 20th century
there's a whole lot going on in nano
long before any initiatives Cornell had
an e beam facility and they actually
were called the National Nanofab in the
late 70s Hank Smith it was the MIT
nanostructures lab in brand new building
39 and it was separate from the ICL
because the techniques were being
developed to get below the micron scale
and well below that this was Hank had
helped invent x-ray lithography later
Rabanne rebranded as extremal to
ultraviolet lithography so this is this
is mainstream nano and again a long time
ago later on or you know somewhat
contemporaneously there was a discovery
of a bunch of synthetic nano structures
whether they were buckyballs nano
tubes graphene and and it was clear to
everybody including me who was not
didn't have access to this technology
that there was something here it was
definitely going to be important how you
would harness this not so clear
semiconductor super lattices for
photonics people you know we're putting
quantum dots in not an organics but into
inorganic materials at the time and I
was kind of reading this as a semi
outsider but there clearly there's
something there in fact I got involved
through a collaboration with Roya mabu
daeun who's a surface scientist in chem
II at Berkeley and this is a problem of
micro mechanical structures and it was a
problem in MIT they tend to stick really
well together because the surface to
volume ratio is high and what was done
was to coat these with self-assembled
monolayers of different types and roya's
later work would be in the microphones
in your pocket allowing them to be in a
humid environment and not end up
collapsing on each other so here's an
example where technologies and multiple
scales are being applied which i think
is important so what about this
initiative in nanotechnology well
there's a guy at NSF micro co Neil Lane
had been the director of NSF and then
went to the White House and Tom Kalil
this is the mid to late 90s and they
decided that we ought to get some
critical mass in this and and and how
did they do that well they worked really
hard
setting up workshop after workshop over
a period of three years to try to build
a case that there was an initiative in
this new kind of technology with the
usual resistance that people hadn't
heard of it
people would say well isn't why do we
need a an initiative based on a unit you
know of nano ten to the minus ninth and
in fact they went and arranged for a W
Tech study and I was on one of these in
99 that know a little later to turn of
the century that look went to Japan and
looked at various things and the
conclusion was that the US was lagging I
felt at the time that Europe was was
doing some outstanding work and
more focused work it's probably true so
what happened there's a House committee
hearing so this is a run-up to go to the
US House of Representatives and someone
asks Richard Smalley who just recently
won the Nobel Prize and he says we
should have a serious national
initiative in this area okay that
carries a lot of weight but it wasn't in
isolation there was support built so
some of you are going to be possibly at
the NSF some of you may be running
institutions like MIT in this kind of
grassroots rather than top-down it's a
huge amount of work it requires people
that are totally committed and I was my
privilege later to work with Tom Kalil
who was also back in the White House in
the Obama administration so what
happened in the end President Bill
Clinton went to Caltech and he gave a
speech and it's Beach said a number of
things the one thing that perked up the
ears of the people in the audience was
that there was a half a billion dollars
for a major new national nanotechnology
initiative and that was a important
event you had Gordon Moore some of you
may know from Moore's Law was at the
time the chairman emeritus introducing
David Baltimore and there's President
Clinton and here's President Clinton
giving the speech which you can read he
misremembered Richard Feynman's name
called him Richard Simon but he did
refer to 40 years before there was work
in nano and Caltech so what is
interesting another quote which I
believe was written by Tom Kalil was
that you would have materials ten times
the strength of Steel shrinking the
Library of Congress into a tiny device
and detecting cancer cells when they're
at a very tiny tumor and so they can be
treated and in fact this is an
interesting statement that these goals
are gonna take 20 or more years to
achieve and that's exactly why this is
something for the government to fund
this is not private capital no one has
an ROI that stretches decades right and
so in fact it
signed this was just at the turn of the
century so it's been a little over 19
years and and it's still going I will
make some comments on that as we go
along here's the funding profile that
you can get at nano gov which is for the
federal government
now there was nano technology funding
already and so it was probably a fifty
and fifty percent increase on a baseline
of around a billion but where you draw
the borders has always been kind of
difficult and you can see the benefit of
grassroots because you would have NSF
NIH do-e DoD and even commerce and a
miscellaneous other people from the USDA
to NASA and all participating so the
money went into all the agencies and was
spread very wide and so you could say
this is a let the thousand flowers bloom
strategy right rather than a hyper focus
now you notice it increased and then
it's kind of stabilized but it's
actually the program is coherent in
other countries around the world in
areas there was a reaction to Clinton
speech this is before the dot-com crash
and so there was a feeling that the US
was on a roll with the silicon valley
telecom boom and that now the US was
going to own the next generation of
technology and so whether it was
Brussels or Beijing or Tokyo people said
we got to get our act together and what
did they do fund nanotechnology in this
case this is like an amplification
factor right to get that kind of funding
going now one thing that is not trivial
and is the re you you can't just have a
nano thing that's going to go forever
right you're gonna have to resell this
Rhian vision at every five years or so
and this is the efforts of Mike and Stan
Williams formerly HP Labs and your next
speaker Paul olive asados from Berkeley
and Lawrence Berkley and Chad Merkin at
Northwestern I
no the third author but you can see
nanotechnology for society convergence
of knowledge technology in society at
some point it gets a little difficult to
keep rebranding this right but you can
certainly work hard and keep things keep
things going I notice this is at the
korea-us nano forum a few years ago so
this was a kind of an international push
and I'd like to contrast that with New
York State which invested a huge amount
of money outside the federal government
and this was at SUNY Albany they have a
silicon fab that was expanded with about
a half a billion of new york state
taxpayer money attracted SEMATECH and
industry consortium and then kept
feeding on itself and growing and
growing to where the claim was there's a
round a twenty billion dollar investment
in infrastructure in silicon nano
electronics giant wafers fab tools and
so in fact the article in The Chronicle
of Higher Education if you build it they
will come was a reference to the fact
that Albany would not be the place that
you would necessarily expect to see this
but it is the state capital of New York
and it was a jobs program it is a major
set of capabilities that would be not as
open by far as a as a university and
it's now SUNY Polytechnic so let me just
save for those that are old enough the
what was at this superconducting
supercollider in Texas was around 10 to
15 billion just for high energy physics
and you have this nano initiative going
on for two decades spending around
twenty five billion a radically
different approach and I think the the
type of research we don't need the the
accelerators for that the physicists
would use and ultimately they concluded
that CERN was quite a good location for
the Large Hadron Collider and pulled the
plug on the funding after they had built
part of it coming from California we
have a train
out in the rural areas that has no
tracks laid but there's some overpasses
and the new governor is trying to figure
out what to do with that you could make
it a kind of park and I don't know in
Texas this hole in the ground you know
what is it being used for it could be
made into a monument for possibly a
lesson for for future generations and if
we ever get the railroad going in 20 or
30 years we'll have those overpasses so
here is here are the kind of projections
that this is something to look at this
is market in Corp markets incorporating
nanotechnology in billions and rather
it's not the nanotechnology market
what's the difference how much do you
capture right in nano this is a 25%
increase per year doubling every three
years now I remember when the MEMS
industry was going at maybe 12 to 15%
it's very difficult to sustain if you're
doubling at every seven or eight years
it means the classes are doubling you
know the number of schools involved
people are working twice as hard or
twice as productive and then continue
and you can't really sustain that so
this I think is extremely optimistic and
nanotech in the mainstream five years
ago three trillion by 2020 doubling
every three years six twelve trillion
dollars that's a lot of money in fact
there was a European article estimating
the global market is a hundred and
twenty four billion in 2024 not 12
trillion so there's a huge ratio but
this is actually the nanotechnology
market per you know narrowly defined and
it's always been a problem in
electronics this silicon semiconductor
is not that important but without it you
don't have the iPhone you don't have
everything so I'm balancing this a bit
but it is this certainly got the
attention of people in the capitals of
the world and so where do I come in well
like I said like vitomir said I've been
in MEMS and Herschel sensing
accelerometers resonators and that kind
of thing
which used nanotechnology as a means to
an end not really building at the nano
scale and I moved to Stanford and
Stanford was part of a network called in
and UN but I moved in 2005 and there was
a recom petition in which Cornell
Stanford and their collaborators
competed against a my MIT Berkeley where
I was and and Urbana I think were the
main schools in 2004 and we lost so it
that and then I moved and so I ended up
in this national nanofabrication
infrastructure network and ultimately I
was a head of the Stanford lab from 2008
2009 and 2011 was in charge of this
whole show so what did that mean well I
got a an insight into the very different
kinds of nano fabs that were around the
country and especially interested in
Harvard's relatively new fab as it was
growing and what the culture was of the
staff and that kind of thing and there
was a recom petition in 2014 where MIT
Stanford Harvard and Berkeley teamed up
with some schools and we actually with
Vladimir's helped at MIT we won in the
end the competition was cancelled it's a
long story but in fact this is a
snapshot from a while ago but if you
look at each of these labs the NSF is
funding it to make it accessible and yet
of course if you have a fab if MIT not
nano in 2025 if you look at the user
community of course most of the users
are from MIT why you kits you walk
across and you're there now the fact is
in 2025 I think there's going to be a
large number of users you could probably
use this color because isn't that about
Harvard Crimson right I think those
people will be writing the T down here
using it and MIT people will be also
using Harvard because the the labs
aren't exactly plug compatible and of
course the companies are involved and
NSF was interested in that
we had we at Stanford have more
companies using the lab and so what's
happened when we had to recompete there
was a company they had no connection to
Stanford Steve Nasiri was an
entrepreneur actually graduate of San
Jose State local school not too far from
Stanford he had a great idea he had a
credit card and so he went in and
prototyped it with some Stanford PhDs in
our lab and in fact that has done really
well if you fly into San Jose the TDK
and ven sense now is on the building and
Cornell had packed bio which had ups and
downs but was one of the early
sequencing single molecule sequencing
and it is in a process of being acquired
by Illumina so these companies we once
went through all the little companies
and tried to make an assessment of what
the impact was but having all these open
labs has been a very good thing that
again has been modeled and adapted to
other parts of the world now here's a
talk I see a lot of grad students and
postdocs I'm not the lead bruce clemens
is the stanford director and the overall
directors oliver brand at georgia tech
and and so you have all of these fabs
around the country that are funded by
the NSF to be open fabs so they won't
say no without a very good reason if you
need their services they have more than
2,000 tools and 67 facilities though
these are the the core facilities and
and you know the one on the red line and
you know the one probably the in upstate
New York and you Penn has an interesting
new fab but there's one that you
probably don't know because I didn't
know until I I've is --it adverse in
attack they have an incredibly strong
Earth Sciences program at Virginia Tech
and their whole fam is oriented toward
natural nano materials but the tools
don't care if it's natural or your nano
material and they're also linked and
it's very small what does that say well
that is a lie
in a remote area of Washington State and
that is called Pacific Northwest
National Lab that many people haven't
heard about they've heard of Lawrence
Berkeley National Lab you know
Brookhaven National Lab what is this
Pacific Northwest National Lab this is a
place where they make nano instruments
that are not made by Fei or other
companies these are PhD scientists with
unique instruments and they love to try
them out on your PhD so that the this
whole thing here could be viewed as a
PhD accelerator for you now if you end
up collaborating with PNNL and you're
going to faculty candidate and there's a
P&L and an L letter rather than all MIT
letters that doesn't hurt either you may
end up being roped into a postdoc or
something so I think actually looking
hard in my case personally the the
personal story I was a Berkeley grad
student and my was frustrated in this 11
mass complex process a tool went down in
Berkeley my adviser said oh call up John
Schott at Stanford because he knew you
know in those days the internet wasn't
quite there so I called him up and he
said yeah come on down and I rode the
library bus back and forth for a week
and I saved several months on my PhD
because they had a similar enough tool I
could adapt the process so if you got
tool problems you can certainly talk to
the management you can even help in some
cases but you can also maybe do a
workaround by FedEx and I think this is
a national resource that is
underutilized and especially at MIT
where you have much of everything you
could imagine but it may not all be
working and it may not quite give you
the image that you need so what what's
what about shared Nanofab what's going
on at Stanford well here is the building
the Paul G Allen building that dates
back from the 1980s well in 1965 we had
an integrated circuit lab that was the
lab I used in the early 80s in the in
1980 there's a proposal for a new fab
that would be a foundry
a it was called the fast turnaround
facility for silicon chips so Jim mindil
who finished his career at Georgia Tech
was driver for that and the building was
built with industry money and it moved
in the IC lab was moved over with some
new equipment and I think it was an
important milestone this purpose-built
large lab Berkeley and MIT were working
hard to catch up and did in the next two
or three years Stanford won that first
inin UN with Jim Plummer and was
co-prime and that injected money and it
changed the culture wasn't the IC lab it
was the Stanford Nanofab NSF would put
pressure on Stanford to bring in users
from other departments from other
schools and that changes the culture
Stanford was part of the next network
with Yoshii own ishi there were other
nano fabs bob sinclar built one that was
SNC now SNF in characterization cam
molar was the first director of the Nano
Center that's now SNS F we renovated the
SNF and then down at the bottom here
sometime in the next decade around the
middle of it we call it the future fab
that I think will we're currently
wrestling with so Stanford is a large
campus at MIT it's nice to be able to
walk very short distances even indoors
especially with the frigid weather you
have today and anyway it's it's it's
been at least it's not raining in
California we've been drenched so
anybody if you look at an aerial view
this is the Allen building the here the
NSF is in here this Stanford nano shared
facility injects a another s making it
almost unpronounceable this is mostly
characterization but some fabrication
and that is run by the Dean of research
SNFs School of Engineering there's a
school of Earth Energy and Environmental
Sciences that was that has too many E's
and they run math specs and mineral
analysis because Stanford geo is big and
have unusual tools that aren't used by
many but they're used they tend to lead
to important discoveries so if you pan
back and look at the campus let's see I
think we can see the Oval and palm drive
the El Camino and the hospital and the
medical school over here and what are
all these things well the this is a map
that I think was made by the d.school
some of these are restricted access some
students may use open access all
students may use there are the product
realization lab d.school proto labs
FedEx why are they on here because they
print stuff right and sometimes that's
useful the art departments on here so
it's is it Nano no it's this complete
wild maker culture the Nano thing I
showed what previously is this corner of
campus but across the street in the
medical school they don't call them
shared labs they call them core labs
because of a change of discussion and in
Stanford unlike MIT doesn't really have
fabs the medical school uses Nano at
Stanford but they have a lot of imaging
and other facilities that are very
useful the EE department has set up a
open electronics prototyping lab and
slack which is not the social media
thing this is this used to be Stanford
Linear Accelerator they have a Nanofab
for zone plates for x-rays that has an
amazing e beam so Stanford is not an
institute of technology at as a
university and it's very distributed and
organization is not our strong suit we
have lots of stuff happening and you'd
need a bike and be in pretty good shape
to go visit all of this I think one
thing that it's been culturally
important this odlo goal is the D school
there's 2,000 users the students or
someone pays $100 for academic /
academic year to get access to these
labs that would go from 3d printing to
melting metal and caste
things and and PhD students sometimes
get benefits but the focus is undergrads
and masters and lab 64 we would have
complemented the Emmy driven D school so
that people can embed electronics so
that culture is going on and then you
come into the cleanroom
people are dressed in white bunny suits
these are the high priests and
priestesses of Technology right there's
a barrier there some people are
attracted to that to be join the
priesthood other people I don't want to
you know how long does it take to get in
this thing you know you don't like to be
in this kind of bunny suit why because
you happen to be a student taking
classes and all but the Nano fabs are
clean because these are all HEPA filters
this is class 100 because of the nature
of the work but we do weird stuff at
Stanford this is a centimeter thick
wafer scaled germanium wimp as a Dark
Matter detector that goes down in a mine
and when I took over I a month later I
got a visit and this is actually a
Berkeley physics student working at
Stanford making this thing with a number
of people Blas Cabrera and physics
visited me with his an entourage of
muscular postdocs and grad students
crowding into my office and the
discussion was the importance of
minority carrier lifetime both in the
abstract and to my personal future that
the lab had to stay clean why was he
concerned because I am the first non MOS
electronics person to be in charge in
the lab he's concerned that the lab will
become too flexible therefore though
there's no Nobel Prize for dark energy
dark matter detection and and it's a
disaster so by the way the centimeter
thick wafers we have special spinners
anchor to the floor because these things
have mass and they're trying to scale up
to larger diameter wafers so what does
our community look like well we stanford
is smaller than MIT and in fact in terms
of
oh but the students are not all
engineering so I'm thinking from the
engineering school we have 250 faculty
total in all of engineering and MIT EEE
EEE CS is a hundred and something right
350 okay all of engineering 350 so we're
somewhat smaller right yeah we're bigger
than Berkeley a little bit in in
engineering so so these are the era's
Yoshio Nishi yours truly and and Nick
melash and materials as a new director
you can see the evolving user community
and we separated the the users and the
ones that almost live in the lab
moderate users and then these light
users and you can see that there's
changes over time and anions started
there there was a student revolt at this
point no kidding
with petitions and frustration because
of excessive industrial use running the
lab into the ground you can see the what
these are Stanford users what's not
shown as there was a huge surge in small
companies and the tools were being run
into the ground and the students were
making any progress so basically that
had some consequences and improvements
and the way things were run and
priorities for the local people and that
I took over and we renovated and then
nnin ends and so if you look at what's
happened is we have a drift from silicon
electronics and and MEMS on silicon to
other substrates materials people are
not doing long process runs a lot of
time they come into the lab and do a few
things then they go to a private lab or
a semi shared lab the rate structure
capped so if you spent a hundred hours
in the in the month the the last twenty
were free so there's an incentive for
groups to send a few students in who
would almost live in the lab and do very
low cost fab that had compliance issues
and we replaced it with a soft cap where
the we bill a certain amount per hour
and then it drops as you go above a
threshold
and that turns out to hurt the
super-heavy users what it often meant is
that it didn't matter now more than one
student was going and some groups would
just load up a single student so in fact
how are we adapting to change well we've
we've launched something called the X
fab which is fast lithography on even 3d
surfaces not necessarily a super
high-resolution doing heterogeneous
things embracing and trying to embrace
in the shared lab 2d transfer processes
and building 3d systems max shoe Locker
also known as Professor shoe Locker
would be one of the pioneers in that
doing his research at Stanford and even
things that aren't really the same like
maybe specialized 3d printing rather
than garden-variety for 3d printing
laser cutters Miller's post machining
all kinds of stuff see what works and we
managed to sell this oh and yes lower
rates so that it's cheaper for the
faculty so the guy that helped launch
this and you know is the faculty
director is John fan this is not a
graduate student this is a professor
okay we have some professors you know
it's it's clear that that's not a
student but not though this guy anyway
he he did his PhD at Harvard cns up the
road he's a Harvard ph.d and he would be
doing some pretty radically interesting
things in nanophotonics and all but even
more radical would be this guy who you
may not recognize because this is a
somewhat older photo this is the break
room the kitchen outside the SNF and
normally we don't see wafer processing
underway in the kitchen if it's a wafer
it's something edible
in fact max is trying to do this carbon
now to transfer process and at the time
the this was he felt a convenient place
this is early in the morning and not
quite compliant so in fact if you're
dealing with synthetic nano structures
maybe you don't have to be that clean in
some cases so ambient processing means
doing it in the room I think he probably
needs safety goggles anyway
this is max euwe Locker a while ago max
couldn't make the talk please tell him
that I've honored him with his early
picture so this kind of on the edges of
Nanofab I think it's very important so
we're now is a collection we have a
clean room that's smaller we have an X
fab that didn't exist we do MOCVD in the
shared lab and we do we've taken over
the management of a lab that's more
electronics prototyping and remember
we're not the whole story there's a
whole bunch of distributed labs going on
so we have 600 users from 24 departments
25 other schools and a hundred companies
large and small and we don't do much
characterization other than inline
characterization and and we this is an
older photo we actually require the blue
kind of lab coats in the in this part of
exFAT so if you look at that we don't
have a new building we have a very old
building and we have managed to renovate
pieces of it that were offices right
we've taken service areas and we've
named them after beaches in California
because it's a distributed lab it's not
all in one location people have to go
out in the hall so it can't be that
clean
we don't have HEPA filter coverage in in
these we we have little mini clean rooms
and we have this system prototyping
facility the the staff have a big open
seating area and that's made a big
difference so you can see the green as
class a hundred X fab might be a
thousand to five thousand so quick
run-through of tools the Heidelberg ma
150 is a workhorse it is used 24/7 so
we're getting another one Harvard has to
why is it nice no mass and if you do if
you want something better than a micron
then you go and use the e-beam and you
still have no mass so it's completely
soft and that's that's huge this one's
not so well known and this is a multi
produce protein patterning tool that has
a Texas Instruments DLP inside and can
resolve one and a half microns you can
remove an anti cell growth layer and
and pattern where cells grow and so that
is a very useful tool we do flip-chip
but it's really flip wafer pieces of
wafer there's a big project it's slack
on linear accelerators on a chip and so
the these are done in a fine placer
we have two inkjet printers that are
used heavily for pretty you know
printing different things at resolutions
that are again not nano but not exactly
anything to sneeze at for some people
that's perfectly fine we do chemistry we
have fume hoods in a dual glovebox and
someone like Jen and Bao who would be an
organic electronics pioneer and major
player
she has students using that because it's
nice to have a lab that you can that's
open that you can use for surge space or
for doing things that would be not
pushing the envelope and a bunch of
other things we do our material transfer
in the glove box and we have polymer
fabrication and we bought some one thing
Stanford's been weak at we haven't had
the kinds of evaporators and sputtering
tools that would be flexible and be able
to deposit anything the battery people
are in there they need some unusual
things they have lots of targets and
they are used very heavily and we're
getting more so I guess the the upshot
of this I'll show and in terms of our
usage but this last one Boris Merman is
a circuits designer and basically he
said what if we had a shared circuits
area not for the undergrads and master
students but for people who really
otherwise would not know exactly how to
interface with TSMC you know if you
haven't done it before if you're you
know I've I've I've had students tape
out but always there's been an IC
professor kind of hand-holding and
making sure there wasn't some rookie
mistake or screw-up and so Boris said
what if we have a facility that would be
staffed by e postdocs and slack that
national lab e's there's a lot of ease
up there and they would help people to
build things
that might have to go into some robotic
system and so it's boards and flexible
stuff and it turned out that has worked
out quite nicely some people need a lot
of help some people don't need help the
first customer Stanford has a lot of
quantitative psychology it was a
psychology prof. that needed electronics
okay so you know it's ubiquitous and so
that group didn't have a lot of EE
internal know-how and so they went for
complete support so one thing that I
think is interesting with MIT dot Nano
is all of these how to process modules
that we are not quite up on the web yet
but like you know things like nickel
silicide bonding the volterra is an odd
kind of fountain pen a tool helpful
hints for grace grayscale lithography
the staff didn't write these these were
written by graduate students in most
cases this is a quick guide to a line
transfer of 2d materials in a glove box
by one of Eric pops students and shadow
mask then there's one thing that I think
is underappreciated and this is by
Archana Kumar who is a former PhD
student she now works at apply materials
on her own time she has gathered all of
the local shadow mass vendors so the
interface of MIT not nano and the whole
Boston area groups have unique knowledge
we're trying to get that in the open so
the real way to build all of this has
been by teaching a course we call these
SOPs or standard operating procedures or
protocols so engineering 241 just
wrapped up believe it or not if you were
at Stanford it's finals week okay
you know I've petitioned the UN to ban
finals in March as a violation of the
Human Rights Convention but Stanford
it's a quarter school right so be happy
that you just finished midterms and that
finals are at infinity in May that's
both faculty and students Stanford loves
the quarter system so we had a two
quarter course that's the next best
thing to a semester course maybe even
slightly better where those two
teams ended up proposing projects and
negotiating with their advisors with the
staff and sometimes external people and
with John and myself to do something
that's useful to the general community
useful to their own research and we pull
in some less experienced students and so
the outcome of that and here's the cost
and we had seventy thousand dollars that
we got from the Dean because that's a
lot of money we have to pay user fees in
the lab we don't have a teaching lab at
Stanford and this wouldn't work in a
teaching lab we want the newest tools to
be developed by the best students and
they get some credit for it it isn't
cheap because that lab we can't absorb
that somehow and by the way Mary tang
the SNFs managing detective director's
signing off because her staffs involved
in every project but we also roped in
the local industry and it turns out
whether large companies are small there
are people who know obscure things that
can share them on using tools that we
may be out of our experience so how is
it working well by affiliation our usage
is you know stable to up the other would
be mostly academics or national labs
mostly internal as always the
interesting with the standing up of X
fab the use of the cleanroom appears to
have dropped until you look at the
multiple labs which means people using
both the cleanroom and X fab wouldn't
how be the majority and so these tools
are getting some traction and I think
the the the number of faculty groups is
up to finally over a hundred faculty
groups and what we would do at a future
fab is somehow informed with this you
probably didn't notice the aerial view
but medicine and engineering or adjacent
on Stanford's campus the Medical School
is extremely interested in getting a new
Nanofab and and we would be interested
in supporting that with them and the
sciences so we would
be more bio focus than MIT nano there is
this s NSF we have earthquakes in
California and other issues that make
the e-beam is in a special building with
a special foundation you know MIT Nano
is a fantastic foundation and and this
new building does and so the e beam goes
in there there's also a flexible
cleanroom that's a yet another cleanroom
I look forward to touring the media labs
cleanroom that is apparently coming up
this lab does things like 3-inch lithium
niobate wafers and all kinds of unusual
processes it was the ginn stone research
labs cleanroom that's now moved over
Bruce Clemens and materials is in charge
and there's a bunch of staff in several
buildings so they have tools that would
be like this
Titan aberration corrected TEM fibs sems
spectra you know the most limit Rolla g
but not all metrology and across the way
from the the SNF so my students would
have counts in both that would use
optical lithography in the SNF and go
over into the s NSF and by the way
there's a contest to name the future fab
and the letter S and the letter n cannot
be used in the name you know because of
tongue-twisting too many Stanford nano
shared facilities so how do we fund this
each school is different cam bowler in
physics now Dean of research and Philip
long and EE they started a nano
committee in 2007 because they were
tired of going to Berkeley to use the
Nano characterization tools and they
managed to get a budget it's a fight
every year
and it varies every year to get tools
acquired for shared facilities and we
sit around the table I was co-chair for
a while and you have a bunch of Dean's I
think there's only one no there's the
engineering Dean the science Dean in
humanities and Sciences the Dean of
research the Dean of Medicine the Dean
of Earth Sciences they all sit around
and we attempt to at
distract investments that would be you
know into this pot of money and then we
go shopping how do we buy things
well we instituted this survey process
of getting to find out what the faculty
need that's a near term thing that's not
really strategic but it does get buy-in
and if it's transparent so here's a page
from an old survey you know who are you
and and whether you're faculty staff
industry is included in the survey and
in a few years ago we have departments
from you know geophysics to biochemistry
to pediatrics radiology surgery you know
it's a whole grab bag and as you imagine
they don't necessarily all line up but
it's sometimes it's surprising how much
cross department supports so gendai on
and material science and engineering
alex done and chemi rowdy wing and geo
all of these different people get to
vote on all of these different tools and
it's all kind of digested and balanced
against strategic initiatives so it it
is a we bought four plasma etch or at
once because there was a tremendous
sense that we were short on plows
matters that were too old
got to get plasma Hatcher's and and then
ended up negotiating a better price by
buying four at once we were playing
vendors off against each other and got a
great deal so in fact I think MIT nano
you know you have leverage and and and
it is a balance between things that
would be bleeding edge and things that
would be workhorse reliable tools so in
any event I am going looking at the time
I don't know if you want to see this
except for I'm gonna skip a lot because
I'm going way long and you and and you
know you can't people are passing out
and there's not enough oxygen at room
but but I'm going to skip through to a
an important paper and important well
I'll tell you this this is an important
paper in 1968 this was an important
paper last summer
this is IBM zurich work showing that the
tunneling current
between a metal-to-metal separated by
some organic molecules you're getting in
the current if you second get do the
second derivative you're getting things
that are related to various mechanical
vibrational modes in the molecule and
and boy that would be neat my thesis was
a chemical sense there was nothing like
this right this is like a spectroscopy
right and the fact it's inelastic
tunneling spectroscopy this is wonderful
but you need to have liquid helium in
order to get that kind of sharpness so
in fact I've had a project since 2011 to
do this electro chemically at room
temperature and the challenge is
designing the interface and designing
the electronics the interface turns out
to be 50 nanometers square but the
business end is a functionalized gold
nanoparticle and you're getting
tunneling currents and attempting to
pull out information let me just jump to
how this was made we decided to use an
STM tip rather than a wafer for various
reasons partly a postdoc that showed up
partly the fact that we didn't have any
printers and if we're going to
functionalize on a single chip we might
as well functionalize on a tip and so we
actually started with a very non planar
substrate it was actually platinum
iridium STM wire and then we made it
even more non-player planar by electro
chemically etching it this is the
substrate we then went to and that's the
SEM Shuang did the animation and we then
the deposited and insulator Ald and I
put in if you look closely you can see
the tips all around this puck that went
into the Ald in the SNF okay that is a
non-traditional fab and we needed to do
that and there was a protocol to verify
cleanliness for the puck and the
reloading procedure and everything else
so in fact how do you pattern on that
spinning is probably not a good idea
focused ion beam isn't quite that
magical
but in fact in practice you can punch a
hole on the end of that and you have
your interconnect and the hole and you
can go do your functionalisation this is
PowerPoint chemistry now the last step
is the best kind is PowerPoint chemistry
if and so so in fact we were going to
mount this in PDMS as an insulator so
that there was only the tip exposed and
we're gonna pull it through backwards
and so we put a microscope here but this
takes good hands this is a manual thing
so what do you do well I don't know
about MIT but at Stanford you find
people that are really smart really good
hands and no coffee now they aren't MIT
undergrads but they're probably in the
local high school so I recruited high
school students to do this and they are
now at various other places at UCLA and
Purdue and as undergrads but any event
that was no mean feat then it goes into
an electrochemical cell and we worked on
the electronics and and the circuit is
just apetencio staff with one minor
difference it's massively lower noise so
there was huge efforts in the signal
processing the data analytics to pull
this information out at room temperature
and Boris Merman who's pictured is is
one of the great analog circuit
designers on the planet analog digital
and he so this is a $10,000 Camry and
this is our little circuit so we could
start a company in potential in
potentiometers but actually there were
other things detecting that you could
see these sort of Peaks from leucine and
deuterated leucine if you can tell these
amino acids to part with a single
deuterium substitution maybe we can do
the kinds of inelastic tunneling like
spectroscopy and do label-free detection
so we got a company going and there are
the founders this is the usual fault
line Brewing Company is walking distance
from our place emmanuel PhD from france
tetani gupta yours truly we have some
values I'm just click
through this and we have been going for
some time and have raised a significant
amount of non venture money and what are
we working on we were funded by DARPA
and are continuing to be funded by DARPA
for sepsis for cytokine panels but in
fact there's a lot of people and this is
Probie Asst work and and in fact Probie
is's use tips obviously we're migrating
to real lithographic nanotechnology and
wafer scale fab but people like peanut
allergen and Salmonella staff and this
is associated with each coli we've had a
lot of work that would be and a paper in
a conference in Toronto of the food
safety people showing that we can do a
very nice assays of nasty things so in
conclusion I think the build it and they
will come is kind of out of that
baseball movie right of what was the
name of it in you know building it and
then the old ball players come from the
earlier era in this case I think the
this is going to be a very busy busy
place because that space in a new
cleanroom is among the most valuable
commodities in any university because it
can be if there's an initiative in an
area you got you can do it and if
there's an issue in another area you've
got the space to do it
so to my ability to advise Vladimir
Denis and and all is very limited but I
I guess at the MIT and over here you
have at the dawn of the nano age okay I
wanted to hit that over here right and
are we at the dawn of the nano age well
I think we are because it's not an age
just to have a few you know when you
transition from one age to another you
have to have traction you have to have
applications you have to have real
technology and I think this lab might be
the place where quantum and other new
computing architectures are developed
you're set up and ready to go I think to
get this
show on the road the strategic
investments I noticed a new faculty
member whose tools are temporarily on
this on the fifth floor
professor nuri will have a some of her
tools in the fab that is exactly the
right idea MIT dot Nano is going to
attract everyone I saw the cryo-em
we call them nobel prize machines in the
basement you know you may want one and
you can go if you're in the bio side
these are incredibly difficult expensive
and to have them in the building is
important I like you know that
prototyping was done in the FIB the FIB
is used a lot as a fab tool not just an
analytical tool and that may depend it
may change what kind of fib you want and
III think there's an opportunity to
launch a course that would bring in
students from engineering and science
and get them busy getting credit
developing new processes documenting
them now you need money for new tools
but actually the old ones are pretty
good this is a tool that's older than
most of the people in the room we just
got rid of it last week and I took this
picture outside the cleanroom there's a
a page on its history this was made in
Wilmington Massachusetts in the 1980s
and shipped out to California the plasma
quest I thought was from Japan but it's
a u.s. tool that I think had Japanese
investment or something I don't know
what the history is but it's finally
gone away it was a very contentious at
her before we got our New Oxford etcher
because it switched from fluorine to
chlorine and the fluorine and chlorine
people were almost coming to blows
beyond the number of days and the week
it was chlorine and fluorine we got a
new at your problem solved so sometimes
you can pacify the restless nano grad
students and I think the the
coordination between MIT Nano and a lot
of other fabs that would include this
interesting one sky water in minute
Minnesota the local one and an Albany
nanotech what do I mean by tool mapping
I tried this at Stanford with a foundry
to indicate the tools in
it easily transferred to the foundry the
foundry wouldn't tell us what the tool
was or what the process was they just
had a green a orange a green a yellow
and a red dot on a process if it was
green it was easy and if it was red it
wasn't there's a lot of small companies
involved in grad students who might want
to commercialize it knowing that you're
on the green tools would mean that you
could move quickly and you could
actually do that for multiple foundries
I think that might be an accelerator an
MIT faculty are going to be developing
new tools they might be interested in
putting them lab and I made this up
before talking to the management today
and that's actually planned we have a
deal where if there's a new vendor or a
new tool from a vendor we'll try to find
space put it in the fab they don't have
to we don't buy it they don't give it to
us they keep title and we'll see what
the usage is you know you experiment and
then if it's six months no one's
interested take it out so I think that
kind of dynamic thing is MIT dot nano
spools up and these in-and-out users
that may not do their whole PhD at MIT
Nano but MIT Nano is critical to the PhD
so they're in for a few steps they go to
the private lab they're back these
people are super important and their
fabrication needs may migrate into MIT
dot Nano and lastly the number one
priority for our future fab is
affordable affordability for the faculty
and that is something where the
institution can help and Stanford
recognizes our fabs have been too
expensive and we're trying to make them
cheaper but in the future if they will
become a lot cheaper how does that
happen you pile up giant amounts of
money it's called the endowment and and
you hope you can invest it and get a
return and use that return to pay
salaries and buy stuff and and then you
offload the it becomes not a full user
facility it's subsidized and that's a
word that we'll that we we are partially
subsidized and that will increase in the
future lastly this is the Stanford
golf course there's a cafe up there and
we went up there actually almost three
years ago and you can see the there's a
mixture of s and F and SNF staff and
Mary would be the managing director
who's done a fantastic job
so acknowledgments I you know I have a
bunch of people including the high
schoolers that helped on that unusual
fab but I will and and the people that
funded it at DARPA but I'll really
emphasize Larry Goldberg is one of these
people in Washington who has defended
the investments in infrastructure in
nano and that isn't easy in the in the
NSF and he's been at it for a number of
years and has been very successful will
there be a successor in 2024 that MIT
might compete for right the successor to
n NCI if it happens Larry will be one
that has has continued to fight for it
so I am over time by a lot but I hope
you found some of this interesting and I
put together things given the fact that
I'm the first in the series it's only up
from here you have Paul alavés Otto's
you have Eli habla Novick okay you may
have heard of him and you have Don I
grew right X IBM almond an atomic guy
and then there's this local guy Bob
Langer right and and so you can see I've
set that and so you can do this sort of
exponential plot and thank you very much
for your attention and I'm open for
questions
I'll leave that open please well hey
thank you for giving us a great start so
you know it's basically you have you
know I was here at the dedication and of
MIT Dano and it was a you know it's an
awe-inspiring thing to pull off this
investment and it is a it's now going to
be it's like the the boundaries of the
painting right do you have the frame and
the canvas and but what is going to get
painted on it is something that is a lot
of possibilities and that's yeah and a
place where we have no space and and we
don't have the ceilings for the tall
tools right that's another issue right
so so there's some envy of where you are
and we hope to one-up you in about five
years we also look forward to sharing
yeah well I guess who this this way I
think I think will be more bio flavored
than MIT because your bio is so already
has such fantastic facilities in your
Institute's so you don't need as much
but anyway if you have any questions I'm
yeah if there any questions we did not
throw the companies out because the NSF
is not happy to get an email from and
some of these companies weren't small
Intel was one of the major users why
would Intel use an academic lab it's
because we have a lot more flexibility
and they would be able to do things
quickly and inexpensively we charge them
more of course but they're very happy to
pay it well the answer would be priority
reservations that the the companies
would be in in some cases their
processes were stretched out because
depending on the crunch tools we
identified what the real problem tools
were
and we actually had kind of a reset
where we did a lot of preventative
maintenance on the tools we just said
stop this you know this so they
basically the I wasn't the Yoshio was in
charge at the time but with that many
students showing up they the this is the
user community there was a response and
the companies in some cases there were
problem individuals that were not that
we're cutting corners because they're in
a company and it's not their lab and
maybe who cares Stanford's rich which is
it's not really as MIT is not really
rich we're very heavily invested and so
so there was a cultural change there was
retraining of people and you know we we
got through that and of course soon
thereafter the economy went soft and
that you know that made it you know sort
of took some of the industry usage way
but but notice you have 40,000 square
feet how many clean room we pull up
there's about a hundred forty thousand
square feet okay it you should measure
it in like hecht acres the metric unit
in our case we have 9,000 square feet of
clean room and these ancillary spaces
would add in a few thousand more so it's
very tight and and I was giving a tour
to our newly admitted grad students who
probably had a tour of MIT Nano and I
said well this is a place where you can
do good work ask ask professor shoe
locker at MIT when you visit there's
still good work to be done here and we
are working hard to get something new
but it's not going to be done by the
time they get their PhD or just at you
know five years out so so anyway it's a
it's a management challenge because it's
an open kitchen and people are cooking
different cuisine blas cabrera i could
ruin his science experiment right by
becoming too loose but their other
faculty in the other ear saying this lab
is rooted in the 20th century MOS
technology and we need to embrace
additional materials and and
and so we have crept very carefully in
that direction and we have duplicate
tools in some cases so there's various
levels of contamination it's it's
manageable
but I think the we have several faculty
abandoned together and have a lab that
would have its own tool set under much
tighter restriction once one of my
students got permission to use an Ald
that was pristine and it made a huge
difference in his PhD to get that really
good hafnia that we couldn't get in the
SNF because the tool has been used for
too many things so Hank you had that
dedicated lab and without it if you were
folded into MTL nanostructures progress
would have happened in a very there may
have been student disruptions and
faculty disruptions so so I'm not saying
the shared lab isn't everything but to
keep a flux of new things in a lot of
what you were working in is now
mainstream right yeah and so so I think
you have to have a thick skin to be in
charge of these facilities right that
Professor Bulova CH gets delegations
from people all the time I'm sure it's
fun yeah it's definitely fun other
questions yeah so okay oh yes hi because
I think there's going to be six months
not long enough to get people to be
interested in new tools how did you deal
with that well we would have a fairly
good effort to promote that to the
faculty the postdocs and the senior grad
students like the company comes in and
gives a seminar and these can be packed
packed seminars and the the tool is
obviously it's it's not just any old
tool there's there's a clear indication
it might be a big win and maybe add
something that is unique
in that national network that we're part
of you know if we can add something new
we can say to NSF hey we can process you
know we'll then advertise that we could
have wafers FedEx from anywhere right to
use it so the company like like the
visibility of MIT Nano there is a
spin-off out of MIT one int no it's inch
fab right the the new spin-off of Parker
Gould and Mitchell Shane our recent PhDs
are not quite PhDs they have a radical
new concept of a lab that's only 1
million dollars instead of in hundred
million dollars it's a it's a smaller
fab with small wafers and this is is
something that if they had a package or
pieces of that that fit MIT it's an MIT
spin-off they should get a red carpet
that's our color right you have this way
so some some sort of like gee wouldn't
it be great if the if the that company
was a success is important because I you
know that's we need new companies and
fab but if it was actually a PhD
accelerator and MIT wouldn't that be
cool
right and so I think that you have the
space to be much more aggressive than we
do we had to take out these old actors
that are still working and people are
reluctant to let them go because they
work right and and the recipe is known
and you know there are people are
uncomfortable it's like a chef losing a
special oven because it's 200 years old
and it's expensive and then they take it
away and you know there's emotional
withdrawal from a plasma edger so if you
haven't been there and some of you may
be in the middle of this you would
definitely that would resonate people
panic right when you when you think
you're gonna lose a capability so we
have to prove that we you know that we
have something that's a drop in place
with that but I think things are
changing fast enough thanks to the push
of
the whole nanotechnology effort it
hasn't quite penetrated the one lab for
instance would be a flavor of
nanotechnology that semi shared outside
right the the main MIT nano and
professor Nuri's work would be even
maybe for you know further out but to
get the first tools here that are were
only accessible to the best students
right you know that ones with good hands
that don't bus stuff because if you
break it it's not really a commercial
tool right to get these alpha versions
not the beta versions is a competitive
advantage for the institution with the
guts and resources and space to do it so
you have things coming out of MIT that
everyone else is racing to catch up with
well yeah which is in a situation normal
for for the last 100 and you know 70
years or so speaking from the west coast
yes did you have to do anything in
particular to attract companies to use
it I know that you're well it's I think
the NSF has helped make it more visible
because people probably would think it's
hey Stanford's private it's not open
Berkeley is less open than we are even
though it's a state school but there's a
way for companies to get in through a
writing a check to a program that funds
the lab in our case we can't do that we
just charge user fees and we charged
twice what the academic fees MIT would
be charged the same as I would be and
the companies get to X in our facility
for reasons that are lost in the midst
of time
our sister lab in some cases charges
three acts and to throttle usage some of
those schools have gone up to five acts
on industry because they have the pot
deep pockets and they'll just take over
and you know is that a problem well
actually the industry ultimately will
cut back right and maybe get their own
tool that the university can benefit
from that revenue stream so the I was
impressed that
Mass General has put a new tool in strim
in the basement right no that is you
know at exactly the kind of thing where
your your engaging that relationship
with Mass General how is that going to
evolve and now it there are people here
using it there's MIT people using an
instrument that MIT didn't buy and so is
that good I think the I think that's a
good thing right to have this lab where
it's open in that way well yeah I will
LA at this point have to thank you okay
yeah no no it's you know we we can keep
on going well there's a reception and
I'm happy to continue to you know
discuss things it is a you know the
culture of each school this isn't
Harvard right this isn't Stanford this
is MIT right and so the the MIT nano
thing that that builds up that works
here will be different and we might
learn some things for our future fab
indeed the goal is need to engage across
the disciplines and you have presented
this very wide way of thinking about how
to approach that before we conclude a
couple of things one there is a
reception on the third floor of MIT Nano
in front of the board room there'll be
some nice snacks please join us
professor how will be available through
about 5:00 p.m. now beyond that before
we do conclude I do want to offer you
this one gift this is our a little token
to you for being the inaugural speaker
of this series it's your very own piece
of MIT nano it's a we took we took a
whole section of the building down for
you okay
but it is the original limestone 400
million years in the making
took us a little while to place the
order from which River in China it's
from the Yangtze Plateau st. plateau and
where they have this unusual rock that
looks like wood right and we have carved
it through them acting in logos just to
make sure you don't forget but thanks so
much for coming here I appreciate that
and we'll put it in my
display of interesting I'm a little
Museum that's about that big of nanotech
and this would be fit right right next
to that so laughs thank you
[Applause]